GRATEFUL THAT ALL OF YOU ARE
WITH US WOULD LIKE TO BE TO
TAKE CARE SOME HOUSEKEEPING AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE ON THE
SAME PAGE REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. TODAY'S DOCKET
WE HAVE TWELVE BILLS ON THE
AGENDA EIGHT WILL BE ON CONSENT
WE WILL HAVE FOR PRESENTATIONS
EACH OF THOSE PRESENTATIONS
WILL BE IN PERSON PRESENTERS
WILL BE SENATOR KABIR SENATOR
BARGES. AND IT'S AN HER. ALL
COMMITTEE WERE BE PRESS. IN THE
COMMITTEE ROOM THIS MORNING BUT
WE'RE GONNA GET TO THE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION INSTRUCTIONS JUST
A MINUTE- AND THEN WE'RE GOING
TO ESTABLISH A CORN. MAZE IN
GENOMMEN IN RESPONSE TO THE
KOBE THE NINETEEN AT MERCY AND
TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES.
WE'RE GONNA NEED TO LIMIT
NONESSENTIAL GATHERINGS IN IT
HERE TO SOCIAL DISTANCING AND
FACE COVERING GUIDELINES. IN
COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE ORDERS
THE STATE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS. TO
NORMAL PRACTICES IN ORDER TO
ENSURE THAT SOME THAT THAT THE
PUBLIC CONTINUES HAVE ACCESS TO
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE
ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO TWO HEARING ROOMS TODAY TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW.
IN WERE ALSO GONNA BE USING A
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE FOLKS WHO WISH TO TESTIFY
TODAY VIA THE TELEPHONE. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO PROVIDE COMMENT
TODAY ON THE BILLS THAT ARE IN
FRONT OF US WE WELCOME YOUR
PUBLIC COMMENT HERE'S WHAT'S
GOING TO HAVE TO HAPPEN IF
YOU'D LIKE TO BE ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE VIA THE TELEPHONE.
CALL IS TOLL FREE THE PARTISAN
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR THE NUMBER IS
CURRENTLY ON YOUR SCREEN. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND JUST ENTER
THE CODE SIX FIVE FOUR. TWO
EIGHT NINE SEVEN WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM YOU.
WHEN WE MOVE THE PUBLIC COMMENT
YOU'RE GONNA BE FRONTED
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION IN PLEASE FOLLOW THE
MODERATOR INSTRUCTIONS. IN THE
UNLIKELY EVENT THAT ANY
INDIVIDUAL IS DESTRUCTIVE TODAY
THAT INDIVIDUAL MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE HEARING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR PHONE CONNECTION
MUTED. WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
TAKE. WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO TAKE
TODAY'S HEARING SLOW AND STEADY
WE'RE GONNA ASK ALL INVOLVED
FOR A LITTLE BIT OF PATIENCE
HERE IN. TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUT
THERE MAY BE SIMILAR LAG TIMES.
FOR PARTIES TO WHO JUST. TO THE
NEW USER ONLINE TOOLS ARE TAKEN
BUT AGAIN. WE'RE GONNA GET
THROUGH IT. LADIES AND OF THAT
SYSTEM A QUORUM MISTER
CONSULTANT IF YOU COULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR MARK.
WATER PRESENT SENATE NIELSEN
YEAH NIELSEN PRESENT SENATOR
DRAW. YEAH DURAZO PRESS. SAID
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER BUT
WIENER PRESENT YOU HAVE A
QUORUM BASINGER CORE HAS BEEN A-
ABOLITION THE SYNAGOGUE IN FOR
COULD LET'S RIGHT. OUR AUTHORED.
WE'RE GOING TO START ON BILL
SIX WE'RE GONNA AND CENTER CUT
YOUR TO PLEASE STEP UP TO. THE
LEAD. WE ARE GREAT THAT CENTER
COPYRIGHT WITH THIS AND I JUST
WANT TO TAKE A IT A MOMENT TO
BE ABLE COULD NOT AND KNOWLEDGE
CENTRE COPY. FOR AND WORK FOR
DEREK IN HER TIE INTO. ON ALL
ISSUE OF HOW. JUST BE CANDID
THIS IS NOT BEEN- AN EASY BILL
TO BE ABLE TO WORK THROUGH A
LOT OF OPINIONS AND SHE HAS
DONE AN ELOQUENT JOB WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE TODAY TO
PRESENT SENATE BILL SIX THE
FLOOR'S YOURS. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR UP FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SB SIX THE NEIGHBORHOOD
HOMES ACT AND THE- THAT
COMPLEMENT ACTUALLY GOES BOTH
WAYS I WANT TO THANK YOU AND
YOUR STAFF FOR YOUR- INCREDIBLE
ATTENTION AND DEDICATION. TO
HELPING US MOVE THIS BILL AND
GET IT TO THIS POINT IT
COULDN'T HAVE BEEN DONE WITHOUT
ALL OF YOUR ASSISTANCE- THIS IS
A REDO OF THE BILL THAT WE
WORKED ON LAST YEAR SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY FIVE AND IT IT IS A BILL
THAT CAME OUT OF THE- SENATE
HOUSING- WORKING GROUP. THAT
THAT WORKED REALLY HARD TO PUT
TOGETHER A PACKAGE THAT MADE
SENSE TO. TRY TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM ONE OF THE CRISIS BIG
CRISIS IS THAT WE HAVE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WHICH IS THE LACK OF
HOUSING PERIOD AND A LACK OF
AFFORDABLE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN PARTICULAR- IN ORDER TO MEET
THE NEEDS OF CALIFORNIA'S
FAMILIES A STATEMENT INCREASE
HOUSING PRODUCTION. YET THE
LACK OF AVAILABLE LAND FOR
RESIDENTIAL DEVELOPMENT
CONTINUES TO BE ONE OF THE
BARRIERS TO BUILDING MANY OF
OUR CITIES ARE BUILT OUT AND
DON'T HAVE READILY AVAILABLE
VACANT LAND IN OTHER CITIES ARE
BASICALLY JUST RELUCTANT. TO
DEVELOP HOUSING ON THE
OUTSKIRTS OF THE RICH
JURISDICTIONS WHICH CONTRIBUTES
TO URBAN SPRAWL SB SIX TAKES
THE CONCEPT. ARTICULATED IN SB
THREE SEVENTY FIVE- SO STYLE
INTO. EIGHT TO REDUCE THE
AMOUNT TIME AND JUST PEOPLE
TRAVEL. BY VEHICLE BY.
SUSTAINABLE COMMUNITIES AND
REUSE AND ADAPT UNDERPERFORMING
PROPERTIES TO CREATE WALKABLE
COMMUNITIES AND AVOID SPRAWL.
THIS ADAPTIVE REUSE BILL WILL
SPUR HOUSING PRODUCTION BY
AUTHORIZING RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENTS ON EXISTING WHAT'S
CURRENTLY ZONED. FOR COMMERCIAL
OFFICE AND RETAIL USE SUCH A
STRIP MALLS LARGE MALLS AND BIG
BOX RETAIL SPACES. SB SIX ALSO
SOLVE AND EVOLVING CRISIS THAT
HAS BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE
SHELTER IN PLACE ORDERS. WHICH
IS SHIFTED BUSINESSES TO ACCEPT
SOME PERMANENTLY NEW WORK FROM
HOME STRATEGIES AND EXPANDED
ONLINE TRANSACTIONS FOR
CONSUMER. RETAIL NUMEROUS MAJOR
COMMERCIAL TENANTS HAVE
INDICATED THAT THEY MAY BE
FILING FOR BANKRUPTCY RELIEF OR
CLOSING STORES. SUCH AS SEARS
JC PENNEY'S KMART AND TOYS R.
US. DUE TO THE DECLINE IN SALES
AT PHYSICAL STORE LOCATIONS. WE
HAVE SEEN A SHIFT IN CONSUMER
PREFERENCES OVER TIME WHICH IS
LEFT MANY COMMUNITIES WITH
STRIP MALLS AND MALLS WITH
MAJOR TENANT VACANCIES. WHICH
CONTRIBUTE TO THE DECLINE OF
RETAIL CENTER. CENTERS INCREASE
BLIGHT VANDALISM AND DECLINE
SALES TAX REVENUE IN MY RURAL
DISTRICT THESE RETAILERS ARE
OUR MAJOR TENANTS AND I EXPECT
TO SEE MANY MORE RETAILERS
LEAVE AS THE ECONOMY CONTINUES
TO STRUGGLE. MANY CORPORATE
ENTERPRISES ARE FORGOING THE
BRICK AND MORTAR OPERATIONS IN
FAVOR OF NEW. WORK FROM HOME
REALITY. M. AND YOU'VE HEARD
ABOUT THE TECH GIANTS FACEBOOK.
AND GOOGLE WHO HAVE BEEN BURKE
IN IN BRACED PERMANENT WORK
FROM HOME STRATEGIES LEAVING
BEHIND MASSIVE COMMERCIAL
CENTERS WITH UNCERTAIN FUTURES
THESE UNDER UTILIZED OR VACANT
COMMERCIAL SPACES ARE ALONG
MAJOR PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION
ROUTES AND CONTAIN SIGNIFICANT
ACREAGE AVAILABLE TO BE
DEVELOPED. FOR MIXED USE
DEVELOPMENT TO CREATE A
WALKABLE LIVE WORK PLATE PLAY
VILLAGE. THE WALKABLE VILLAGE
CONSTABLE ALSO HELP TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS BY
CREATING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
REDUCE THE NUMBER OF VEHICLE
TRIPS RRANDS BY LOCATING
SERVICES WITHIN WALKING
DISTANCE. MOST SIMPLY SB SIX
WILL SPUR HOUSING PRODUCTION BY
ALLOWING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
APPROVE RESIDENTIAL OR MIXED
USE DEVELOPMENT ON COMMERCIALLY
ZONED RETAIL SPACE BY UTILIZING
AN EXPEDITED PROCESS. REQUIRE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT TO MEET OR
EXCEED THE DENSITY DEEMED
APPROPRIATE TO ACCOMMODATE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SUCH AS
APARTMENTS TOWNHOUSES AND
CONDOMINIUMS AND PROVIDE
FLEXIBLE FLEXIBILITY FOR LOCAL
DECISION MAKING BY SUBJECTING
THE DEVELOPMENT TO LOCAL
PLANNING PARKING AND DESIGN
ORDINANCE. WITH NO COST TO THE
STATE. S. SIX WILL IN. RESIDENT
DEVELOPMENT WITHOUT IMPACTING
SINGLE FAMILY NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND THE BILL WILL SPUR ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY A CRITICAL COMPONENT
TO ECONOMIC RECOVERY DURING
THIS- POST- PANDEMIC. THE
PERIOD OF TIME WITH ME TODAY
TOMORROW AND IF I IF I COULD I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES FOR BRINGING TO MY
ATTENTION A TECHNICAL FIX WHICH
WILL BE MADE IN FUTURE
AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY THAT SB
SIX. PROJECT MUST COMPLY WITH
ALL THE REQUIREMENTS. IN THE
BILL IN ORDER TO BENEFIT FROM
THE PROTECTIONS AFFORDED BY THE
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. SO
WITH ME TODAY IS MELANIE BRADY
MONTEREY COUNTY HOUSING AND
SPECIAL PROGRAM SERVICE
MANAGER. AND JOHN. BURLING
PRESIDENT OF TODD CO GROUP AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM SENATOR
ALL RIGHT SO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WAT WE'RE GONNA DO
IS WE'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM OUR
TO LEAD SUPPORT WITNESSES. EACH
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS WILL HAVE
THREE MINUTES TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THEIR TESTIMONY WILL
GIVE EACH A THIRTY SECOND PROP.
FOURTEEN GONNA TAKE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN THREE DIFFERENT
WAYS WILL START HEARING FORTY
TWO OR THREE THEN WE'RE GONNA
GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY AND
THEN WE'RE GONNA GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE. SO LET'S
START RIGHT NOW WITH OUR FIRST
LEAD WITNESS THAT'S WELCOME
MISS BRANDI TO COMMITTEE
MISBRANDED YOU HAVE THREE
MINUTES AND THE FLOOR IS YOURS
YOU'RE IN COMMITTEE. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS MELANIE VARIETY AND
I'M THE HOUSING A SPECIAL
PROGRAM SERVICES MANAGER FOR
THE COUNTY OF MONTEREY. THE
COUNTY OF PLEASE TO SUPPORT AT
SIX SENATOR. WHICH WOULD OFF
RESIDENTIAL THE- ON THE LAW
CURRENT BOUNCE COMMERCIAL AND
RETAIL. SB WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
PORTION THE HOUSING ABOUT BE
DEDICATE AS OF HOW. LOCALLY
ADDITIONAL AFFORDABLE HOW OF IN
THE PART. BECAUSE NINETEEN PAN
BECAUSE OMEGA THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL HOW UNITS. AT SIX
WITH HER OP. AND ALLOW THE
COUNTY AND ARE LIKE THE BILL.
TO BUILD CREDIT NEEDED THE
HOUSING MARKET RATE AND UNITS.
ARE YOU INFELD ABOUT. IN RURAL
COUNTIES SUCH AS- IN
IMPROVEMENT AT THE CORE HOUSE
IN CREATED BARRIER THAT CAN
RENDER ENOUGH HOW PROJECT IN.
YLIDES ABOUT HOW THE ON SITE
THAT ARE HAVE ORACLE TO FIFTEEN
IN SEWER SIR. REDUCES THE NEED
FOR HIGH CALL INPUTS. THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS LARGEST STORES
CLOSED NUMBER CAN MORTAR LOW.
CAN BE HELD THROUGHOUT THE- AND
MY COUNTY IS NOW EXACT EXCEPT.
IN NOR LIMA OUR LARGEST CITY AT
NOW SHUTTERED KMART STORE OF
HIGH ONE OH ONE AND HERE'S TO
THE EAST OF THE ONE OF. TARIAN
AIR BLIGHTED. YES THEY ALSO
UPPER FOR READ THE- AND READ.
GIVEN THEIR PROXIMITY TO SHOPS
TRAIN AND SCHOOL. A CROSS
COUNTY AND ITS CITIES MANY.
STRUGGLE ORANGE CASES THEY CAN
MALLS OFFICE OFF THE PART COULD
OFFER AMPLE UP. FOR A PROJECTS
SUPPORT FOR THE THAT THE
DEVELOPMENTS. FOR COMMERCIAL
THAT CAN TO HAVE LARGE UNDER
YOU'LL PARTY LOT. SIXTEEN CAN
EASILY A DESIGNED MAKE USE OF.
OFFERED. ANYWHERE GRATEFUL
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN COMMITTEE
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OUR SECOND
AND FINAL LEAD WITNESS ON SB
SIX THE GENTLEMAN'S NAME IS
JOHN ELDER BRING OUT HE'S THE
PRESIDENT OF TENANTS AND OWNERS
DEVELOPMENT CORPORATION. JOHN
WE WELCOME YOU COMMITTEE YOU
HAVE THREE MINUTES THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. BOB GOOD MORNING JEREMY.
I'M JOHN OVERLY SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF BUILDING FOR FAST CAL.
MAN SUPPORTERS BILL. BACK THAT
IS AN ACTIVE AN ACTUAL PROJECT
INSIGHTS ONE WHERE FOUR CENTS
CITY KY. TO AFFORD HOUSING. AND
BUILDING COMPLETES YOU THAT FOR
EVERY IN THE GOLD STATE. I
THANK YOU COMMITTED TO SMART
SISTER AND EQUITABLE TO. THANKS
WE'VE THE NEEDS OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS HELPING CAN AFFORD.
QUALITY ECONOMIC GROWTH.
PROCEDURES SB SIX THE RIGHT
BILL AT THE RIGHT TIME TO. THIS
GOAL. SB ONE WALKED ON OF SAL
OF MILES OF- URBAN AND SHOULD
FROM DOES. AROUND TO. OF MIND
HEART. TRANSIT FIVE OPENING THE
DOOR TO MIXED USE RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENTS HERE TO STILL
SUBJECT TO LOCAL DESIGN
STANDARDS CENTER LOCAL PROJECT
APPROVAL SB SIX WILL RESULT IN
YOU EVERY DAY AT THE TOWN
CENTER WHAT ARE THE IMPACT ON
THE NEARBY NEIGHBORHOODS. SB
SIX THIS PREVENTS TO A WHOLE
HEALTH WITHIN THE CITY PROJECTS.
SO MORALLY IMPAIRED INSTEAD
FORWARD WHICH ABSOLUTE YES SO
BACK THE ALL THE COMMUNITIES OF
OUR STATE. CONTRACT SB SIX IS
THE MOST EXTENSIVE AND THE BIG
HELP YOU ALMOST JUST EVER
PROPOSED. DON'T JANUARY **** A
PER SO HUNDRED WATER STATEWIDE
ABOUT. 51% ARE SUPPORT WHAT ONE
THIRTY THREE ARE. THE PORTABLE
SAYS YOUR CHILD THANK SOME OF
THE CAR OUT THAT ALL S. B. C.
OFFERED FOR YOUR- ON THIS WITH.
NOW THE FUTURE CAN. WE WOULD
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC
COMMENT TODAY TO PLEASE STATE
YOUR FIRST AND LAST NAME YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL AND THE
ORGANIZATION THAT YOU REPRESENT
SO LET'S START RIGHT NOW AND
FORTY TWO A THREE YEAR WE'RE
CHECKING IN FORTY TWO THREE WE
DO NOT HAVE ANY INDIVIDUAL
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK AND
REPUBLICAN AND- WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO TO ROOM TWENTY FORTY THAT
CHECK IN WITH ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. NO ONE IS ROOM ROOM IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY SO NOW THAT
IS INJENICA MAYBE WE'RE GONNA
OPEN UP OUR TELECONFERENCE ON A
MOROCCAN ASK INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE HOLDING TO PLEASE. BE
PREPARED TO OFFER A PUBLIC
COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
META MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
QUEUE UP ALL THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE'RE
CURRENTLY LOOKING FOR THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT IF YOU CAN
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO IF
YOU'RE IN SUPPORT OF SB SIX
MADAM MODERATOR WILL GO TO YOU
FOR OUR FIRST CALLER. THANK YOU
LINE TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. SKINNER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JENNIFER AFTER THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS WE'RE HERE IN SUPPORT
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
HER LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CATCHING
THE MOMENT FORWARD THINKING.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENT THAT
THAT'S GOOD FOR NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AUDREY
RETIRED CHECK ON BEHALF OF
WESTFIELD IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH I AGREE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU BY THE MODERATOR- MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THAT YOUR BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL REPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH JEREMY WE
APPRECIATE YOUR- COOPERATION IN
THESE EFFORTS THAT'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
I'M THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD
WE. MISTER TAYLOR THIS IS BOB
NAYLOR I REPRESENT FEEL SEVEN
COMPANY AN ORANGE COUNTY
BUSINESS STRONGLY SUPPORTING.
MORE HOUSING OF ALL KINDS
EVERYWHERE THIS IS A VERY GOOD
BILL WE SUPPORT SB SIX THANK
YOU THANK YOU SO MUCH BYE
APPRECIATE YOU CALLING IN
MADAME MODERATOR NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU AS A REMINDER TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE DO HAVE ONE MORNING HERE TO
JUST BE ONE MOMENT FOR THEIR
NUMBER. IN. ONE THIRTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
EVERYBODY LOVED HER CALLING ON
BEHALF BETTER WE CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH MISS
LOPEZ. BETTER MODERATOR TO HAVE
ANY ANY ADDITIONAL COLORS IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIX. THANK YOU I
DO HAVE ONE FINAL ONE IN Q. AND
THAT'LL BE FROM LINE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE WOULD BE
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION HERE IN SUPPORT-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER BERRY PATIENT YOUR PHONE
CALL. BETTER MODERATOR ANY
ADDITIONAL INDIVIDUALS IN
SUPPORT. I HAVE NO FURTHER LINE
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME ALL
RIGHT LAYS IN GERMAN THANK YOU
SO MUCH BETTER MODERATOR WE'RE
NOW GOING TO GO TO THOSE WHO
MAY BE OPPOSE FOR LOOKING FOR
THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED TO SB SIX
WE HAVE THREE ROUNDS OF
POTENTIAL PUBLIC COMMENT BUT
START RIGHT NOW IN ROOM FORTY
TWO OR THREE WE DO NOT HAVE
ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX AND FORTY
TWO OR THREE. WE'RE GONNA GO%
CHECK A ROOM TWENTY FORTY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. RICKETS IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY WE'RE NOT GOING TO
BE GOING TO OUR TELECONFERENCE
NINE. WE'RE GOING TO ASK- META
MODERATOR TO PLEASE Q. ALL
THOSE WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIX. TO PLEASE
Q. WHAT NOW MADAM MODERATOR.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND OVER TO ONE TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING JERRY MEMBERS MARINO
WHITE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING CONSORTIUM AND ALSO ON
BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE MARC
DIVERS AT THE CALIFORNIA
HOUSING PARTNERSHIP AND
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION TO SB
SIX. UNLESS AMENDED TO REQUIRE
HOUSING DEVELOPMENT THAT ARE
ALLOWED ON THE I THINK THAT AT
LEAST 20% OF UNITS FOR LOWER
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS. AGING CLUED
GUARDRAIL IN THE SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE REQUIREMENT
AND ENSURE THERE IS SUFFICIENT
ACCESS TO WORKERS FOR
CONSTRUCTION TO PROCEED WITHOUT
EXTREME. DELAYS AND AT
REASONABLE COST. AS YOU FAMILAR
TO OUR HERE WE CAN. I'VE THE
AFFORD RICK. WERE VERY. STAGE
TO SEE IF THAT THE AUTHOR HAS
INCLUDED PLACEHOLDER LANGUAGE
BUT- ENCOURAGE HER TO INCLUDE
THE 20% REQUIREMENT- CONSISTENT
WITH AB ONE FIFTEEN I'M IN THE
ASSEMBLY WHICH HAD SIMILAR
POLICY- ADDITIONALLY. WE
BELIEVE THAT PROJECT BENEFITING
FROM MILLION YES REFORM SUCH AS
THOSE AND A THE STATE SHOULD
SUPPORT HIGHER WAGE
CONSTRUCTION JOBS AND REQUIRE
THAT YOU CAN SKILLED AND
TRAINED WORKFORCE. HOWEVER WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT THEY'RE
THIS DIVISION NUMBER OF WORKERS
IN EACH CRAFT TO HELP AND- IT
AND TO DO THAT WE URGE YOU TO
CONSIDER. EMPLATE MODIFICATION.
TO IT THE SKILLED AND TRAINED
REQUIREMENT WHICH- WE PROVIDED
IN OUR LETTER. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY. THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
COMMENT TO ADD THAT WILL BE YOU
FIRST OF OUR PRIMARY OPPOSITION
WE'RE WE'RE GRATEFUL THANK YOU
MARIA I'M NOT A MODERATOR LET'S
GO TO OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK
YOU I'M TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES HI MY NAME IS FRANK
MARTINEZ I'M CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF NONPROFIT
HOUSING. WE WANT TO ECHO
SIMILAR CONCERNS- PARTICULAR
ABOUT THE STRICT SKILLS IN
TRAINING WHICH WE THINK
ULTIMATELY THAT WILL LEAD TO
FEWER AFFORDABLE HOMES BUILT IN
CALIFORNIA- AND- WE ALSO ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE
AFFORDABILITY REQUIREMENTS WE
WANT THOSE. TO BE STRENGTHENED
THAT IS ALL WE HAVE- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING US CAMP-
TO COMMENT THANK YOU THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE APPRECIATE YOU
CALLING IN THIS MORNING. BETTER
MODERATOR LET'S GO TO OUR NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU I'M
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ADAM CHANCE THE CONTACT THE
HOUSING ACTION COALITION NOT
OPPOSED BUT CONCERNED ABOUT
ECONOMIC FEASIBILITY OF NEW
HOUSING THANK YOU THANK YOU
ADAM WE APPRECIATE YOU CALLING
IN WITH YOUR CONCERNS NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU RIGHT
TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALLEN CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
BAY AREA COUNCIL AND WE ALSO
APPLICABLE FOR THAT DATE-
NOTING THE SILICON ALREADY
BROUGHT UP REGARDING THIS
COUNTRY. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR YOUR CALL IT'S GOOD
OR NOT CALLER. THANK YOU AS A
REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME AND
WE'RE GOING THIRTY TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING CARE AND
MEMBERS AND I DO NOT LIKE HOW
PUBLIC AFFAIRS CALLING ON
BEHALF HI OF. BURKE CALIFORNIAN
AND HABITAT FOR HUMANITY
CALIFORNIA- WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR HER LEADERSHIP
ON HOUSING PRODUCTION BUT WE
ARE CONCERNED WITH THE MEASURE
AND WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH HER IN
HER OFFICE. TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH OF YOUR PHONE TODAY.
BETTER MODERATOR LET'S GO TO
OUR NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THE MODERATOR
IT CAN WE PLEASE DO A LAST CALL
FOR OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME THANKS JOHN
MATTER MODERATOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH TO ALL THOSE WHO COMMENTED
TODAY BOTH IN OPPOSITION AS
WELL SUPPORT WE'RE GONNA BRING
IT BACK TO COMMITTEE. WILL ALSO
WELCOME A MOTION AS WELL IF ONE
OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS SO
CHOOSES SOME OF WE HAVE A
MOTION MOTION ON THE FLOOR BY
CENTER DRIVE SO WE'RE GRATEFUL
TO CENTER DRIVE SO IS. ON THE
COMMITTEE THIS YEAR WE'RE
EXCITED ABOUT IT- I JUST WANT
TO START IT REAL QUICK BUT
SOONER CABALLERO AND WE'RE
GONNA TURN IT OVER TO SEE IF
THE VICE CHAIRS AND WE- HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS CENTER DRAWS OF-
MADAM SENATOR YOUR VIEW YOU'RE
COMMITTED TO THE ISSUE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. BUT YOU
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT I JUST
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
LEAVE THIS HEARING BECAUSE THIS
IS BEEN ONE YOUR TOP. FOCUS
AREAS OF THE BILL IS MAKING
SURE THAT THERE IS AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PERCENTAGE DEDICATED-
MADAM CENTER TURN OVER TO YOU
ON THAT ONE. I APPRECIATE THAT
MISTER CHAIR LET ME JUST SAY
THAT- AFFORDABLE HOUSING HAS
BEEN THE WHOLE REASON I ENDED
UP GETTING INVOLVED IN HOUSING
IN THE FIRST PLACE AS A LAND
USE ISSUE. I'M ABSOLUTELY-
COMMITTED TO IT- WERE I'M
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH
SENATOR SKINNER BECAUSE I WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT- THAT THE
FRAMEWORK OF THE DENSITY BONUS
WORKS WITH THIS AND THAT IT IT
STARTS TO SET A MINIMUM. AMOUNT
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT
NEEDS TO BE DONE- BUT I ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE IT IT IS-
THEY WERE GONNA GET SOME
HOUSING BUILT HEY THAT DOESN'T
MAKE ANY SENSE TO PASS
SOMETHING THAT. THAT THAT
DOESN'T RESULT IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF NEW HOUSING SO-
AND I'M ALSO COMMITTED QUITE
FRANKLY TO LOOKING AT
HOMEOWNERSHIP BECAUSE I THINK
WE NEED TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF PEOPLE THAT OWN THEIR OWN
HOMES AND- THIS IS ONE OF THE
WAYS WE CAN WE CAN GET THERE IF
THEY'RE DONE AS CONDO SO. I'M
COMMITTED THIS IS THE FIRST
COMMITTEE HERE THIS YEAR I
EXPECT IT'S GOING TO GO THROUGH
SOME ITERATIONS WE'VE- WE'VE
GOT MORE COMMITTEES TO GO
THROUGH AND I DO HAVE A
COMMITMENT- TO LOOK VERY
CAREFULLY AT THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE CAN.
TO BE TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY.
QUESTION OR COMMENTS MEMBERS WE
DO HAVE EMOTIONAL THE FLOOR WE
HAVE A MOTION FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. PLEASE AT SENATOR
AWESOME. THANK YOU. MISTER
CHAIR AND I. REALLY WANT TO
COMMEND. ECHO YOUR WORDS OF.
COMMANDING THE AUTHOR. FOR ALL
OF HER HARD WORK- SHE HAS BEEN.
EXTREMELY RESPONSIVE. TO ALL OF
THE ISSUES THAT ARE.
LEGITIMATELY BEING RAISED- IN
HOW YOU DO IT TO. BALANCE THIS
OUT IS A- IS A- AGAIN TO BE
COMMENDED COMMENDED I'M A
PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR. FILE
HAVING WORKED OF THE AUTHOR
AND- THE HOUSING WORKING GROUP.
ARE AND RAISE THESE ISSUES OVER
AND OVER BUT THE FACT THAT YOU
ARE INCLUDING. A CONCERN NOT
ONLY OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
HOUSING IN GENERAL. AND IN
AREAS AND IN NO IN SUCH A WAY
THAT. TAKES ADVANTAGE OF THIS
OPPORTUNITY OF THIS OUR
PREVIOUS US. COMMERCIALLY
ZONED. AREAS IT WAS SO. SMART
EVERYBODY'S LIKE. OF COURSE
THAT'S A THAT'S A NATURAL. AND
YET DON'T THINK ABOUT ALL THE-
IN THE WEEDS. THE WORK THAT HAS
TO BE DONE AND THEN JUST
FINALLY- I KNOW THAT YOU. CARE
NOT ONLY ABOUT THE HOUSING BUT
YOU CARE ABOUT THE PEOPLE. WHO
HOPEFULLY CAN GET INTO THE
HOUSING EITHER TO BUY OR TO
RENT SO THAT MEANS THEY HAVE TO
HAVE. THE KINDS OF. WAGES AND
SALARIES. THAT THEY NEED. AS
WELL SO. AND THE- SKILLS THAT
ARE NEEDED SO I JUST WANT TO
REALLY COMMEND YOU I THINK THIS
IS REALLY GOOD AND- ALL OF YOUR
HARD WORK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH CENTER. YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM COMMITTEE. HERRING C. NINE
CENTER COVER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR- LET ME JUST
SAY THAT THAT PART OF WHAT I'VE
BEEN TRYING TO DO IS AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR COMMENTS
CENTER DRIVE SO IF THIS CAN
WORK IN MY DISTRICT AND CAN
WORK IN YOUR DISTRICT THEN IT I
CONSIDER IT EXCEPT THE SUCCESS
HAS MANY TIMES ONE SIZE DOESN'T
FIT ALL IN CALIFORNIA- THE GOAL
HERE IS TO GIVE. AUTHORITY TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO MAKE SOME
CHOICES IN THEIR COMMUNITY
ABOUT WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO
PUT HOUSING AND WHAT COMMERCIAL
ZONES ARE GOING TO DO THE
TRANSITION TO SO THIS DOESN'T
TELL LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHAT THEY
HAVE TO DO THIS GIVE THEM
OPTIONS INCREASE THIS EXPEDITED
PROCESS AND YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT I AM COMMITTED TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING JUST LIKE
I'M COMMITTED TO. A LIVABLE
WAGE AND SO ANYWAY WE CAN DO
THIS THAT AND HAVE IT WORK IS
REALLY IMPORTANT TO ME SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND- AND CONTINUE TO MAKE
THE COMMITMENT THAT THIS IS A
WORK IN PROGRESS AND I WANT TO
GET EVERYBODY TO THE TABLE TO
MAKE SURE WE'RE GETTING. I WANT
TO GET I WANT TO GET THE
HAUSER'S TO BE IN SUPPORT AND
SO I GOT SOME WORK TO DO AND I
WILL DO IT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
ANNA CABALLERO AND AGAIN THANK
YOU SANDRA FOR YOUR WORK CENTER
WIENER AS ALWAYS AS CHAIR OF
HOUSING FOR A HE'S TREMENDOUS
WORK IS WELL UNDER THE VICE
CHAIR ALL RIGHT MR. NOW IF YOU
TO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE CAN. ON HOW.
SO MCGUIRE. BY WHAT. HI NIELSEN.
ALL RIGHT. NIELSEN HI SENATOR
DORADO. DORADO HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER
WIENER HI FOUR ZERO THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE'RE GONNA KEEP THE
ROLE OPEN EYES CENTER WIENER I
DO BELIEVE WE HAVE A REFERRAL
OUR AWARD WINNER HERE TODAY-
FOR FIRST OF THE YEAR THAT'S
COMMISSIONER HERTZBERG TODAY. I
WAS EVERYWHERE YOU LOOK. FAT
THAT'S VERY TRUE- ALL RIGHT
WE'RE GOING TO GET BACK TO YOU
ON THAT. THANKS FOR WATCHING.
THANK YOU MATTERS THERE YOU GO
TO LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE GOING
TO IN FILE ORDER IF WE'RE GOING
TO DO SOME DISINFECTING NUMBER
GONNA INVITE CENTER GLAZER DID
GET TERROR FIRMER ENDED TO BE
TO COME FORWARD IT'S SENATE
BILL SIXTY FOCUSING ON
PRESIDENT SHORT TERM RENTAL
ORDINANCES WE APPRECIATE HIS
WORK LAST YEAR THIS YEAR ON
THIS ISSUE- AND THEN WE'RE
GOING TO BE HEARING FROM
SENATOR BURGESS AT WERE
BERKELEY SHOULD THE BOTH
AUTHORS. SENATORS ARE THE FLOOR
IS YOURS ON SB SIXTY THANK YOU
CHAIR THANK YOU CHAIR MCGUIRE
APPRECIATE IT. THIS BILL IS AS
YOU MENTIONED SIMILAR TO A BILL
LAST YEAR S. B. TEN FORTY NINE
WHICH PASSED THIS COMMITTEE-
NOT JUST PASSES COMMITTEE
PASSED THE SENATE. PASSED ALL
COMMITTEES IN THE ASSEMBLY GOT
OFF THE SET ASSEMBLY FLOOR- BUT
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE OF THE
MIDNIGHT DEADLINE WAS NOT ABLE
TO COME BACK FOR CONFIRMATION
ON OUR SIDE SO. IT'S COMING
BACK IN SIMILAR FORM IT WOULD
GIVE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS MORE
TOOLS TO ENFORCE ORDINANCES.
THEY ADOPT REGULATING SHORT
TERM RENTALS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. THE ECHO OF IT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC HAS LED TO AN
INCREASE IN PEOPLE USING SHORT
TERM RENTALS. TO OF A PUBLIC
HEALTH RESTRICTIONS ON LARGE
PUBLIC GATHERINGS- SHORT TERM
RENTALS OFFER A WAY TO IMPROVE
TOURISM AND EARNED HONOR SOME
EXTRA MONEY. RECENTLY THEIR
PROLIFERATION HAS ALLOWED BAD
ACTORS. TO USE THE PLATFORM. TO
ADVERTISE IN SECURE HOMES FOR
LARGE PARTIES. OFTEN IN
VIOLATION OF LOCAL ORDINANCES.
POST COMPLIANCE WHICH GATHERED
DATA ON SHORT TERM RENTAL
PROPERTIES IN MORE THAN A
HUNDRED CITIES IN THE UNITED
STATES FOUND A- TWO HUNDRED AND
50% SPIKE IN COMPLAINTS FROM
JUNE TO SEPTEMBER COMPARED WITH
THE SAME PERIOD LAST YEAR. SO
WAS A PROBLEM BEFORE AND IT'S
CERTAINLY HAS GOTTEN WORSE IN
THE LAST HALF OF TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN FORTY TWO PEOPLE WERE
SHOT INSIDE OR JUST OUTSIDE A
SHORT TERM RENTAL PROPERTY
NATIONWIDE SEVENTEEN PEOPLE
DIED. ONE OF THE WORST OF THESE
INCIDENTS HAPPENED IN MY OWN
CITY OF ORINDA. WHERE FIVE
PEOPLE WERE KILLED IN A MASS
SHOOTING AT A LARGE HALLOWEEN
PARTY IN. TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN
AT A SHORT TERM RENTAL PROPERTY.
SB SIXTY IS AN IMPORTANT BILL
THAT GIVE CITIES AND COUNTIES
THE POWER TO ENFORCE THEIR
LAWS. IN A WAY THAT WILL HELP
KEEP THEIR RESIDENTS SAFE. AND
GET THE ATTENTION OF THOSE WHO
ABUSE THEIR RIGHT TO RENT OUT A
HOME. WITH ME TODAY TO DISCUSS
THE BILL ARE ORINDA MAYOR. AMY
WORTH. N. RICHARD DAY SAN
LAZARO FROM EXPEDIA WITH THAT
MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SIR GRAYSON
AGAIN WE APPRECIATE YOUR WORK
ON THIS THIS IS NOT BEEN AN
EASY SUBJECT SO I THANK YOU FOR
TACKLING IT THAT LAYS IN GERMAN
WE'VE TO LEAD WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT TODAY EACH LEAD WITNESS
WILL BE GIVEN THREE MINUTES IN
THE THIRTY SECOND PROBLEM.
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO THE MAYOR
FROM THE GREAT CITY OF ORINDA
AMY WORST NIGHTMARE AT THE
FLOOR IS YOURS YOU'RE NOW IN
COMMITTEE. YOUR CHAIR MCGUIRE
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THIS
MORNING- IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL SIXTY. THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE CITIES WITH AN
IMPORTANT TOOL IN MANAGING THE
SHORT TERM RENTALS IN OURS. IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES AND WE ARE SO
VERY GRATEFUL FOR SENATOR
GLAZER. FOR SUPPORTING THIS
LEGISLATION AND ALSO TO ALL OF
YOU WHO SUPPORTED THIS- THE
LAST- IN ITS LAST- ASIAN LAST
YEAR. YOU WILL RECALL THE
TRAGIC MURDERS ON HALLOWEEN
NIGHT FIGURING DEATH THAT
OCCURRED AT AN ILLEGAL
GATHERING IN THE SHORT TERM
RENTAL THIS UNSPEAKABLE TRAGEDY
WAS DEVASTATING TO THE FAMILIES
OF THE VICTIMS AND TO OUR
COMMUNITY. IN SHORT TERM RENTAL
HOSTING PLATFORMS CAME INTO
EXISTENCE MANY CITY CALIFORNIA
CHOSE TO BAIL THEM COMPLETELY.
IN A ROOM ON THE OTHER HAND WE
CHOSE A MORE MODERATE APPROACH
TO PERMIT THEM IN ADOPTED
NORMAN'S THE CLEARLY OUTLINED
THE RULES. THAT INCLUDED NO
RENTALS FOR LARGE PARTIES IN
THE REQUIREMENT THAT SHORT TERM
RENTALS REGISTERED THEIR
PROPERTY. OPTIONAL ORDINANCE
STEPHENS WORKED WITH PROPERTY
OWNERS AND NEIGHBORS TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS AND COMPLAINTS WHICH
REQUIRES EXTENSIVE STAFF
RESOURCES BUT IT ALSO REQUIRES
THE ADMINISTRATIVE TOOL. I DO
AFFECTED ENFORCEMENT. FOLLOWING
THE HALLOWEEN TRAGEDY WE
FURTHER STRENGTHEN OUR
ORDINANCE TO RESTRICT RENTALS
TO HOSTED RENTALS WHICH UNITE
MINIMUMS HOWEVER REDUCE
CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE IS THE
ABILITY TO ENFORCE THE RULES
INTERFACES SERIOUS VIOLATIONS.
COMPLIANCE SHORT TERM RENTAL
PROPERTIES WITH LOCAL ZONING
ORDINANCE IS THE RESPONSE TO
TRUST RESPONSIBILITY OF BOTH
THE PROPERTY OWNER IN THE SHORT
TERM RENTAL PLATFORM. HAVING AN
ADEQUATE FINE STRUCTURE IS
ESSENTIAL TO BE ABLE TO
EFFECTIVELY MANAGE AND ENFORCE
THESE REASONABLE ORDINANCES.
ARAMBULA LIKE MANY CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA IS A GENERAL LAW
CITY IN THE STATE LEGISLATURE
SETS THE STATUTORY LIMITS
REFINE. THIS BILL WOULD PROVIDE
A MUCH NEEDED TO OPPORTUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA TO ENFORCE THEIR
SHORT TERM RENTAL ORDINANCES SH
IN THE SAME FASHION THE CHARTER
CITIES CURRENTLY ARE ABLE TO DO.
WE RECOGNIZE THE DURING THE
CALL BUT A WHOLE NEW ASPECT OF-
THE RISK. INVOLVED IN ON
ENFORCEABLE- SITUATIONS AROUND
CALIFORNIA WETTEST TO GET
INCREASED URGENCY. IN ADOPTING
ITS ORDINANCE SO WE DEEPLY
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT LAST
YEAR SENATE BILL- AT. TEN FORTY
NINE AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT THIS IMPORTANT
SHORT TERM RENTAL BILL. IN THIS
SESSION SB SIXTY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE
MATTER KNOW HOW BUSY YOU ARE
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR WORK
BOTH FOR THE CITY OF ORINDA AND
ON THIS IS A VERY SPECIFIC
ISSUE. LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE
GOING TO NOW GO TO OUR SECOND
AND FINAL LEAD WITNESS FOR
THREE MINUTES WE'RE GONNA HEAR
FROM RICHARD DAYS SAM LICCARDO.
REPRESENTING THE EXPEDIA GROUP.
MISTER DAYS SAM LICCARDO THE
FLOOR. IS YOURS HERE NOW AND
COMMITTEE. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MORE. THE I REJECTED
HIM ROSE YOU MANAGE OF
GOVERNMENT COMMUNITY AFFAIRS
FOR GROUP OR FOR ACROSS BRANDS
VACATION RENTALS- ABOUT-
GRATEFUL TO BE- WANTS TO IT'S A
OF THE POLICY THIS TIME AT SB
SIXTY. IT IS PROUD TO WORK WITH
CITIES AND COUNTIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA TO SUPPORT BALANCED
RESPONSIBLE FOR CRITICAL
REGULATIONS THAT EACH EACH
COMMUNITY. LOCAL THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS IMPORTANT SCHOOLS
IN PORTAGE REGULATIONS INSTEAD
HIGH EXPECTATIONS AROUND
COMMUNITY HEALTH AND SAFETY.
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR SENATOR
GLAZERS APPROACH THIS ISSUE
RESPECT WE URGE COMMITTEE
MOVIES LEGISLATION FORWARD-
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND PEER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS CHALLENGING
ISSUE. THANK YOU SO MUCH REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU CALLING IN TODAY
LAYS IN GERMAN WE'RE NOW GOING
TO GO TO THE OTHER INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT WE HAVE
THREE LAYERS THAT WE'RE GONNA
GET THROUGH WE'RE GONNA ASK FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND WE'RE
GRATEFUL YOU'RE WITH US. WE'RE
FIRST GOING TO START HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY INDIVIDUAL WISHING
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY
WE'RE NOT GOING TO CHECK IN IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WE DO NOT
HAVE ANYONE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY. IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY NOW WE'RE GONNA GO
TO OUR TELECONFERENCE LINES
THIS IS WHERE WE'RE GOING TO
ASK INDIVIDUALS TO BE ABLE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY
MATTER MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
Q. ALL THOSE WISHING TO TALK IN
SUPPORT. OF SB SIXTY EIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND FIRST REPORTED NUMBER
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ON WHAT YOU'RE A MEMBERS ON THE
GROUND ON THE HOW THE LEGAL
CALIFORNIA CITIES LIKE THAT
THANK THE AUTHOR. FOR HIS WORK-
ON THE CONTENT YOU KNOW WORKING
ON HIS BACK. AND WORK WITH YOUR
COMMITTEE WHILE TO GET TOWARDS.
I APPRECIATE THE WORK THANK YOU
SO MUCH THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONFERENCE CALL NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. THANK YOU LINE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS
SHALL BE AS THE LEAD SHOT ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA AND REPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR THE PHONE CALL
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK YOU
I'M FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING AUDRA HARTMAN WITH
PUBLIC POLICY ADVOCATES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA HOTEL
AND LODGING ASSOCIATION LAST
YEAR WE SUPPORTED SB TEN FORTY
NINE WE ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT SB
SIXTY THIS YEAR. AND WE URGE
THE COMMITTEE TO PASS THAT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR CALLING
IN TODAY NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AND I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR THE MODERATOR
THOSE WERE FOLKS IN SUPPORT OF
XP SP SIXTY WE'RE NOW GOING TO
CHECK IN WITH THOSE WHO MAY BE
OPPOSED WE'RE GONNA CHECK IN
HERE IN FORTY TWO OH THREE WE
DO NOT HAVE ANYONE WANTING TO
SPEAK. AGAINST SB SIXTY THIS
TIME WE'RE NOT GOING TO CHECK
IN IN ROOM TWENTY FORTY ROOM
TWENTY FORTY NOTHING HAPPENED
IN THERE NO ONE IN OPPOSITION
WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE. WE'RE
GOING TO ASK THE MODERATOR TO
PLEASE QUEUE UP ALL THOSE FOLKS
WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIXTY TO
PLEASE DO SO NOW. MADAME
MODERATOR. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE'RE CURRENTLY LOOKING
FOR THOSE WHO MAY BE IN
OPPOSITION OF SB SIXTY THIS IS
OUR FINAL CALL FINAL CALL FOR
THOSE TURN OPPOSITION OF SB
SIXTY MADAME MODERATOR. THANK
YOU IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME NICE JOB ABOUT
A MONTH LATER THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR GOING TO BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE WE'RE GOING TO SEE IF
THERE ARE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS OR IF. ANYONE LIKE
ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO ADVANCE
EMOTIONS. WE HAVE A MOTION WITH
A MOTION BY SENATOR WIENER AYE
MOTION BY CENTER WIENER
QUESTIONS COMMENTS CONCERNS BY
THE COMMITTEE. CURRENCY NINE
CENTER GLAZER G. LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU ARE CHAIRMAN GLIDER
THANK YOU AND YOUR WONDERFUL
STAFF FOR HELPING THAT WORK
WITH US ON THIS BILL AND FOR
MANY OTHER STAKEHOLDERS WHO.
KNEW THAT I WASN'T TRYING TO BE
MEAN SPIRITED HERE WE'RE TRYING
TO BALANCE THE INTERESTS AND
TRY TO. TAKE SOME A MODEST BUT
IMPORTANT STEPS TO IMPROVE OUR
COMMUNITY SAFETY I WANT TO
THANK THE WITNESSES WHO HAVE
TESTIFIED IN THOSE WHO ARE IN
SUPPORT AND WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH THE
MOTION BY CENTER WINNERS IT DO
PASSED THE FLOOR MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE FLOOR. MR DON'T
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR
MCGUIRE HI WIRE HI SENATOR
NIELSEN HI NIELSEN HI SENATOR
DORADO HI ROSARIO. HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG. SENATOR WIENER.
RIGHT WIENER HI. BORDERS AS YOU
GENERAL COMMITTEE THAT
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO
VOTES AS CENTER GLAZER WE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PRESENTATION OR TO
KEEP THE BILL. ON CALL TO ALLOW
THE MAJORITY LEADER TO ADD ON
HERE SHORTLY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT. PLEASE IN GENERAL
COMMITTEE WERE NOW GOING TO BE
MOVING FORWARD TO SENATOR
BRIDGES WE WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU JUST
FOR JUST FOR HIS PATIENCE IN.
WAITING TODAY THIS IS A REALLY
GOOD BILL FOCUS ON THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN. IMPACTED IN
PARTICULAR AT BY THE DENTIST
WILDFIRES THE STATE'S THIS IS
SB THREE OH THREE SB THREE OH
THREE CENTER MORE JUST FOR
YOURS. FOR THANK YOU GERMAN
ACQUIRE AND- MEMBERS BOB FOR A
LONG ME TO PRESENT A THREE OH
THREE A BILL THAT WOULD EXTEND
THE TIME ALLOWED FOR THOSE
WHOSE PROPERTY WAS DAMAGED OR
DESTROYED BY A DISASTER TO
TRANSFER THEIR BASE YEAR VALUE
TO A REPLACEMENT PROPERTY.
CALIFORNIA HAS SEEN
UNPRECEDENTED NUMBER OF
WILDFIRES OVER THE YEARS. THAT
HAVE DESTROYED MANY HOMES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THIS IS
LEFT COUNTLESS RESIDENTS
DISPLACED IN A FIGHT AGAINST
THE CLOCK TO MEET THE FIVE YEAR
DEADLINE. ALLOWED TO ACQUIRE OR
CONSTRUCT A REPLACEMENT
PROPERTY. AND QUALIFY FOR
TRANSFER OF THEIR BASE YEAR
VALUE. AT A TIME WHEN THESE
DISPLACED RESIDENTS WERE
BEGINNING TO PUT THEIR LIVES
BACK TOGETHER. FOLLOWING THESE
DEVASTATING WILDFIRES COVERT
NINETEEN HIT BRING CRITICAL
SECTORS OF GOVERNMENT IN THE
ECONOMY TO A GRINDING HALT. DUE
TO DELAYS AS A RESULT OF THE
PANDEMIC SOME RESIDENTS WERE
NOT ABLE TO MEET THEIR
DEADLINES OF REPLACING OR
REBUILDING. SB THREE OH THREE
WOULD RELIEVE SOME OF THE
PRESSUREPUT ON THESE RESIDENTS
BY EXTENDING THE DEADLINE BY
TWO YEARS TO ALLOW ADDITIONAL
TIME TO REBUILD. OR REQUIRE A
REPLACEMENT PROPERTY. FOR THESE
REASONS I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE ON SB THREE OH
THREE COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU FOR
ALL YOUR WORK ON THIS AT CENTER
BOARDS DISTRICT- IT LAST YEAR
WAS JUST IMPACTED DEVASTATED
BY. THE CREEK FIRE IN GRATEFUL
FOR HIS WORK HE'S VERY HANDS
ON- IN APPRECIATE HIS EFFORTS
ON THIS CRITICAL ISSUE. FACING
GERMAN WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO IS
WE'RE GONNA GO TO OUR LEAD
WITNESS WE HAVE ONE LEAD
WITNESS TODAY. THAT'S THE
CALAVERAS COUNTY ASSESSOR
LESLIE DAVIS WE APPRECIATE WE
APPRECIATE STATUS BEING ON WITH
US MISS DAVIS IS GONNA HAVE
THREE MINUTES MISS DAVIS WILL
GET A THIRTY SECOND PROMPT. AS
SHE GETS CLOSE TO THAT TIME
MISS DAVIS GOOD MORNING.
WELCOME TO COMMITTEE THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. GOOD MORNING AND
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM LESLIE DAVIS
CALAVERAS COUNTY ASSESSOR. AND
SPEAKING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SENATE BILL THREE OH THREE. I
WANT TO THANK SENATOR BOARD
JUST FRAUD DURING THE BILL AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THE HARD WORK OF
HIS STAFF. INCLUDING MAKING
DECISIONS AND DATA JORGENSEN.
THIS BILL RECOGNIZES THE STATE
WIDE IMPACT OF THE CODED
PANDEMIC. I'M PROPERTY OWNERS
WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO OVERCOME
THE IMPACTS OF A LARGE SCALE
DISASTER. IN THE WAKE OF A
DISASTER GOVERNMENT SWOOPS IN
WITH INFORMATION AND HELP. BUT
SURVIVORS MANY OF WHOM ARE IN A
STATE OF SHOCK. NEED THE BASICS
LIKE A PLACE TO LIVE. WITHIN
DAYS OF THE BUTTE FIRES
DESTRUCTION SURVIVORS WERE
BUYING OR RENTING ALL AVAILABLE
PROPERTY AND THE HOUSING SUPPLY
IN CALAVERAS COUNTY WAS
DEPLETED. THE RESULT WAS THAT
MANY WERE LEFT OUT IN THE COLD.
IN THE WAKE OF THE GREAT
RECESSION WE LOST MANY IF NOT
MOST OF OUR RESIDENTS. WHO'D
BEEN IN THE BUILDING TRADES.
THAT COUPLED WITH UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT DEBRIS REMOVAL AT
INSURANCE SETTLEMENTS. CREATED
OBSTACLES TO REBUILD. IT IS
BEEN A LONG PROCESS FOR MANY OF
OUR RESIDENTS WHO ARE NOW IN
THE MIDST OF THAT FIVE YEAR
DEADLINE. AND WE'RE NOT ALONE.
IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY FIFTEEN
WHEN THE BUTTE FIRE SWEPT
THROUGH CALAVERAS COUNTY. IT
WAS THE FOURTH MOST DESTRUCTIVE
FIRE IN CALIFORNIA AT THE TIME.
IT GIVES ME NO PLEASURE TO NOTE
THAT THE BUTTE FIRES. NOW
RANKED NUMBER EIGHTEEN. SENATE
BILL THREE OH THREE WILL EXTEND
TO HELP HAND IS. ACROSS STATE
HAVE BEEN HIT BY A DOUBLE
WHAMMY FIRST A NATURAL DISASTER
THEN A PANDEMIC. THE CALIFORNIA
ASSESSORS ASSOCIATION HAS TAKEN
A SUPPORT POSITION ON SENATE
BILL THREE OH THREE. TOGETHER
WITH MY COLLEAGUES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK THIS
MORNING. DAVIS THANK YOU SO
MUCH MISS DAVIS IS A CALAVERAS
COUNTY ASSESSOR WE APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK AND COLLABORATION ON
THIS PLACE IN GERMAN WE ARE NOW
GOING TO BE GOING. BACK TO
THOSE WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE OH THREE THREE WAYS TO
PARTICIPATE WE'RE GONNA START
RIGHT NOW ROOM FORTY TWO OR
THREE. CENTER DRIVE SO WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYBODY HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE SO NOW WE'RE
GOING TO GO LOOK IN ROOM TWENTY
FORTY. TWENTY FORTY. LONELY IS
ROOM HERE ON A THURSDAY WE'RE
NOW GOING TO BE GOING TO OUR
TELECONFERENCE LINE. WE'RE
GONNA CHECK IN TO SEE THOSE WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF. SB THREE OH
THREE MADAME MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE Q. THOSE IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE A THREE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME- SHOULD EVERYONE'S
PATIENCE FOR THE CAN FOR THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
THREE. POSTS IN SUPPORT OF SB
THREE OH THREE MADAME MODERATOR.
AS A REMINDER IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH
MATTER MODERATOR WE'RE NOW
GOING TO BE LOOKING TO THOSE
WHO MAY BE OPPOSE WE WANT TO
REMIND FOLKS THAT YOU CAN CALL
IN ANYTIME EIGHT FOUR FOUR.
1-116-364-8442 NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR ENTER THE CODE
THAT'S ON YOUR SCREEN- AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING YOUR
COMMENTS ON THE BILLS THAT ARE
IN FRONT OF COMMITTEE TODAY.
WE'RE CURRENTLY LOOKING FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION
WE'RE GOING TO START HEARING
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE NO ONE
IS IN FORTY TWO OH THREE LET'S
GO TO OUR OVERFLOW ROOM IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY KNOWN AS IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GO TO OUR TELECONFERENCE
LINE WE'RE LOOKING FOR THOSE
WHO ARE IN OPPOSITION OF SB.
THREE OH THREE MADAME MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE Q. THANK YOU IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE.
AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONCE
AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. A MODERATOR WE'RE GONNA
DO A FINAL CALL FINAL CALL FOR
OPPOSITION FINAL CALL PLEASE.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND I HAVE NO COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME THANK
YOU SO MUCH READING MODERATOR
ALL RIGHT WE'RE NOT GOING TO
LOOK TO COMMITTEE MR VICE CHAIR
FOR COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS TO MR
VICE CHAIR WE'RE ALSO WELCOMING
A MOTION AS WELL BUT LET'S GO
TO. THE VICE CHAIR FOR A
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I HAVE
NONE BUT I WILL MAKE THE MOTION
TO BE PASSED THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER RIGHT SURE WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO THE DEAN OF THE
SENATE WAS WITH THIS YEAR AS
VICE CHAIR. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND CENTER NIELSEN WE HAVE A
MOTION ON THE FLOOR MOTION ON
THE FLOOR NEED TO SHOW
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE. HEARING SEEN NINE
CENTER MORTGAGE WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE PLEASE. THANK YOU.
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN FIVE PRETTY
ROUGH- IN ADDITION TO THE
PANDEMIC WE ALL KNOW THAT- THE
CREEK FIRE- LARGELY MY
DISTRICT- IS CONSIDERED THE
WORST WILDFIRE IN CALIFORNIA
HISTORY HAVING DESTROYED.
AROUND THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND ACRES SO THIS IS BEEN
DEVASTATING- TO FOOTHILL AND
MOUNTAIN COMMUNITIES- AND THAT
IS CERTAINLY AN UNDERSTATEMENT-
SOMETIMES. A STORY IS THE BEST
WAY TO UNDERSTANDING THE ISSUE
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE THE
BUTTE FIRE BURNED DOWN THE HOME
OF A COUPLE IN MY DISTRICT.
THEY BEGIN THE REBUILDING
PROCESS FOLLOWING THE FIRE IN
THE FIRST ESTIMATED COMPLETION
WAS IN- NOVEMBER OF NINETEEN
WHICH IS FURTHER ADJUSTED- TO
THE LATE SUMMER OF TWENTY
TWENTY JUST IN TIME FOR THEM TO
REALIZE THE BASE VALUE
TRANSFER. WHEN KOBE HIT IN
EARLY TWENTY TWENTY THREE
THINGS HAPPENED. FIRST THE
CONTRACTOR STOP CONSTRUCTION
FOR A TIME FOLLOWING THE STATE
RECOMMENDATIONS SECOND THE
SUPPLY CHAIN SLOW DOWN. IN
THIRD IN THE INTEREST OF HEALTH
AND SAFETY THE CONTRACTOR
LIMITED THE NUMBER OF WORKERS
AND SUBCONTRACTORS ALLOWED TO
WORK ON THE PROJECT ALL AT ONE
TIME. ALL THESE WERE REASONABLY
INTEND TO PROTECT THEM THE
HEALTH AND WELFARE OF WILL OF
THE LABORS AS A RESULT IT'S
BEEN SEPTEMBER TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AFTER THE FIRE THE
HOUSE WAS NOT READY TO BE
FINALIZED BY THE BUILDING
DEPARTMENT. THIS COUPLE MADE
EVERY EFFORT TO START THE
REBUILDING PROJECT EARLY ENOUGH
TO MEET THE DEADLINE BUT HIT A
ROADBLOCK THAT NO ONE COULD
HAVE FORESEEN COLLEAGUES SB
THREE THREE IS NECESSARY TO
EXTEND THE DEADLINE FOR THIS
COUPLE IN SO MANY OTHER RATHER
RESIDENTS. IMPACTED BY FIRES
SUCH AS THE CREEK FIRE WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED DELAYS IN SUFFERING
AS A RESULT OF THE PANDEMIC I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. PATTERSON
EMERGES THANK YOU FOR THIS
BILL- THE MOTION IS ON THE
FLOOR BY CENTER NIELSEN THE
MOTION IS A DO PASSED YOU
APPROPRIATIONS MISTER NOW CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR MCGUIRE BY REQUIRE HI
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN HI
SENATOR DORADO. DORADO HI SEND
HERTZBERG. THANK YOU ABOUT. I
HERTZBERG BY SENATOR WIENER AYE
WIENER FIVE FIVE ZERO ZERO FIVE
ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT THAT
BILL IS THAT WE'RE CLOSING THE
ROLE THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND- BURGESS WE ARE
NOW MOVING ON TO OUR FOURTH AND
FINAL WE WILL NEED TO TAKE UP
OUR CONSENT CALENDAR IS WELL
BUT LET'S GO TO OUR FOURTH AND
FINAL BILL OF THE DAY FOR
DIRECT PRESENTATION AND THAT'S
CAN BE COMING FROM OUR MAJORITY
LEADER MAJORITY LEADER SENATOR
HERTZBERG. THIS IS ON S. B. TWO
SIXTY SEVEN ON ACTIVE SOLAR
ENERGY SYSTEMS. MAJORITY LEADER
THE FLOOR IS YOURS WE WELCOME
YOU TO COMMITTEE AND TO US AND
WE WILL BE PRESENTING YOU WITH
THE RICARDO LARA WAR TODAY.
PLEASE PRESENTED TO THE LAST
PERSON IN COMMITTEE EACH
COMMITTEE HEARING. RITUPARNA
JEEZ. THAT'S WHAT THEY SAY
ABOUT ALL THIS OLD GUY- YEAH.
SO THE CUT WHAT WHAT THE
CONSTITUTION SAYS. THAT EVERY
TIME A PROPERTY TRANSFERS OR
PROPERTY ADDED TO A PARTICULAR
PROPERTY THE STATE HAS ABILITY
TO GRAB A BITE AND TAKE TAXES
OUT OF THAT. THE WE'VE PASSED
THE CHANGE IN THE LAW SOME
YEARS AGO IN ORDER TO SUPPORT
THE PUBLIC POLICY OF ENHANCING
OF INCLUDING SOLAR IN PEOPLE'S
HOMES AND TO TRY TO INCENTIVIZE
THEM TO SAY THAT THAT SUCH AS
SOLAR. INCREASE WITH DR SORRY
INCLUSION INTO THE PROPERTY
WOULD NOT BE. A TAXABLE EVENT
THAT WOULD ADD TO YOUR ASSESSED
VALUATION. CHALLENGE THAT WE
FACE IN THE PRACTICAL REALITY
OF IMPLEMENTATION IS. THAT THE
WAY MANY OF THESE COMPANIES
ACTUALLY ARMED PLACE ALL ONE
PEEPERS PROPERTIES IS THE NEW
PARTNERSHIPS AND THERE'S
TRANSFERS WITHIN THOSE
PARTNERSHIPS THAT ARE BASICALLY
THE ECONOMIC MODELS TO. ALLOW
FOR THE STUFF TO WORK AND SO
THIS BILL CLARIFIES ANY
CONFUSION IN THAT REGARD THAT
ON THE ONE HAND SUPPORTS THE
POLICY THAT SAYS IF YOU WANT TO
ADD SOLAR TO YOUR HOME IT
SHOULD NOT BE INCLUDED IN THE
ASSESSED VALUATION. AND THE
OTHER HAND AVOIDS THE CONFUSION
THAT'S CREATED BY WHAT'S CALLED
THESE PARTNERSHIP FLIPS- IN
ESSENCE WHERE OWNERSHIP SHIFTS
FROM ONE TO ANOTHER BASED UPON
YOUR PAYMENTS NOW YOUR HISTORY
WORKS IT'S JUST SIMPLY. A
MECHANISM THAT THE MARKET USES
THAT PUTS LESS PRESSURE ON
PEOPLE WHEN THEY COME AND
INSTALL A SOLAR INTO THEIR
HOMES ON THE ONE HAND. AND
WANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
UNDERLYING PURPOSE OF THE
EXCLUSION IS MET AND NOT-
IMPEDED BY A STRAINED
INTERPRETATION OF HOW WE
FINANCE THESE THINGS AND SO
THIS IS A CLARIFICATION OF THE
LAW THAT'S WHY I'VE INTRODUCED
IT. THAT'S ITS PURPOSE THAT'S
WHY I ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE
RICK YOU OFF OF THE SOLAR
ENERGY INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION
IS ONE OF MY WITNESSES TOGETHER
WITH DAN NELSON. OF A MINUTE
ENERGY ANTOLINI HUNTER. Q.
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH WE'RE
GONNA BE GOING TO OUR TO LEAD
WITNESSES THAT WILL WILL START
WITH RICK I'M OFF WHO IS THE
SUIT FROM THE SOLAR ENERGY
INDUSTRIES ASSOCIATION. RECALL
HAPPENED THREE MINUTES THREE
MINUTES TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY AND I'LL GIVE A
THIRTY SECOND PROMPT. RICK GOOD
MORNING WE WELCOME YOU TO
COMMITTEE THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO APPEAR BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE
TODAY. IS A PROUD SPONSOR AT
THE TWO FIFTY SEVEN. HE IS A
NATIONAL TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR
THE SOLAR INDUSTRY ACROSS THE
FULL VALUE CHAIN OF THE
INDUSTRY OUR MEMBER COMPANIES
ON BEST SELLER SEVENTY BILLION
DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA TODAY.
SEVEN REQUIRE. ACTUALLY YOU
DON'T BETWEEN THE CURRENT
PROPERTY. OF YOUR MEDICAL OR
FINANCING STRUCTURE THE
PARTNERSHIP. PARTNERSHIP
STRUCTURES ARE USED TO FINANCE
MOST SOLAR ENERGY SYSTEMS
CALIFORNIA- AND CAME ABOUT AS A
WAY TO MAXIMIZE THE USE OF THE
FEDERAL INVESTMENT TAX CREDIT.
YOU NEED TO KEEP TAX MEASURES
WORKING DRIVE DOWN COSTS THAT
MAY SELECT ONE OF THE CHEAPEST
ENERGY SOURCE ON THE PLANET. SB
TWO SIXTY SEVEN PROVIDERS
SIMPLE PACKAGE OR EQUIVOCATION
THAT PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
CERTAINTY TO SORT ABOUT CLINTON
ASSURANCE CALIFORNIA CAN REMAIN
A GLOBAL LEADER IN. THE
DEVELOPMENT AND INSTALLATION OF
SOLAR- I HAVE TWENTY ANY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR. WE'RE NOW TO GO TO A
SECOND IN FINALLY IN THE CAN BE
NELSON. DEAN IS A- EIGHT MINUTE
ENERGY IT IN WERE IN. WE WILL
YOU THE FOR OR- EACH THANK YOU
AND THANK YOU CHAIRMAN REQUIRE.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO YOU
THIS MORNING- I AM WITH EIGHT
THEN IT SOLAR ENERGY WE ARE A
LARGE DEVELOPER OF. UTILITY
SCALE SOLAR POWER PLANTS
PRIMARILY IN CALIFORNIA- THE
PARTNERSHIP. SELECT IS THE
MECHANISM THAT WE USE TO
FINANCE. ARE VIRTUALLY EVERY
PROJECT WE'VE EVER DONE. IT
ALLOWS AS- AS RICK EXPLAINED.
IT ALLOW THE FEDERAL TAX
CREDITS TO BE OUR- OPTIMIZED
AND MONETIZED TO ENSURE THAT
THE COST OF THE OVERALL SOLAR
POWER SYSTEM IS LOW AS IT CAN
BE- PROVIDING THE LOWEST COST
OF ENERGY TO THE CUSTOMERS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN- ARE WE BECAME CONCERNED
THAT- THE WAY THAT A
PARTNERSHIP SCHLEP WORKS WE CAN
AGREE COULD BE INTERPRETED TO.
TRIGGER A CHANGE OF CONTROL AND
THAT SUBSEQUENT LOSS OF THE
PROPERTY TAX EXCLUSION. AND THE
LEGISLATURE- ENACTED
LEGISLATION IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN TO PROTECT PARTNERSHIP
SLIPS FROM. TRIGGERING A CHANGE
OF CONTROL AND SO WE ARE
GRATEFUL TO OUR CENTER
HERTZBERG FOR PROPOSING THIS
LEGISLATION TODAY THAT WILL
ENSURE THAT INDEED PARTNERSHIP
SLIPS ARE PROTECTED FROM
REASSESSMENT BY TRIGGERING A
CHANGE OF CONTROL. TO PROVIDE
THE CERTAINTY OF OUR PROJECT
PIPELINE SO THAT THEY CAN BE
FINANCED AND THAT THE BILLIONS
CAN BE INVESTED IN THE STATE
CREATING THOUSANDS OF
CONSTRUCTION. JOBS THANK YOU SO
MUCH. RESHIPMENT SENESCENT YOU
SOME FOR YOU PHONE CALL I DO
ANNE HUNT WILL BE THE LINE
PREPARED TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS. GOING
THROUGH OF COURSE THE MAJORITY
LEADER ON THAT ISSUE LAYS IN
GERMAN WE'RE NOW GOING TO BE
LOOKING TO THREE LAYERS OF
PUBLIC TESTIMONY TWO ROOMS AND
ONE TELECONFERENCE LINE. TWENTY
GIVE YOUR PHONE NUMBER.
844-291-6364 EIGHT FOUR FOUR
TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE SIX
FOUR. CALL US LET US KNOW IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK AND THAT
CODE ADD TO BE ABLE TO GET
ANYONE TO DIAL IS SIX FIVE
FOUR. TWO EIGHT NINE SEVEN
WE'RE GONNA FIRST START HEARING
ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE WE DO
NOT HAVE ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN FORTY TWO OH THREE
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY WITNESSES IN ROOM
TWENTY FORTY. WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF SB TWO
SIX SEVEN WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
ROOM TWENTY FORTY WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE'RE GONNA
TURN IT OVER TO MATT A
MODERATOR. NOT A MODERATOR IF
YOU CAN PLEASE QUEUE UP THOSE
WHO ARE IN SUPPORT. SUPPORT AT
S. B. TWO SIX SEVEN. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND WE'RE
FIRST GOING TO GO TO LINE CAN
YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
CHAIR AND MEMBERS CAN STONE OF
STONE ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND STORAGE
ASSOCIATION IN AT THE ETHICS
REPORT. THANK YOU SO MUCH
CAMPUS ECON IN ITS GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE AND A
MODERATOR. THANK YOU OF MINE
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ON
BEHALF OF THE INDEPENDENT
ENERGY PRODUCERS GOING TO COURT
THANK YOU SO MUCH ME
APPRECIATED THAT'S GO TO OUR
NEXT CALLER. THANK YOU A LINE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS OF THE- FERRARI ON
BEHALF OF SUNPOWER CORPORATION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU APPRECIATE
YOUR PHONE CALL THANK YOU SO
MUCH NEXT CALLER PLEASE. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
AFTER CARE MEMBERS THIS IS
DANIELLE OF BURNELL ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN CLEAN POWER
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA HERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH DANIEL. WE'RE NOT
GOING TO GO BACK TO OUR
MODERATOR AND WE'RE GONNA DO A
LAST CALL LAST CALL FOR THOSE
WHO WERE IN SUPPORT LAST CALL
FOR THOSE IN SUPPORT AND S. B.
TWO SIX SEVEN MATTER MODERATOR.
THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO MAKE A
COMMENT IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU SO
MUCH READING MODERATOR WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE LOOKING TO
THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED THREE
LAYERS LET'S START HERE IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE NO ONE IS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
IN ROOM FORTY TWO OR THREE.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GO TO ROOM
TWENTY FORTY OPPOSITION ON SB
TWO SIXTY SEVEN. NO ONE IS IN
ROOM TWENTY FORTY IN OPPOSITION
WE'RE NOW GOING TO TURN IT OVER
TO OUR TELECONFERENCE LINE.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR IF YOU'D
LIKE TO COMMENT WE'RE NOT GOING
TO BE GOING TOWARD
TELECONFERENCE LINE WE'RE
LOOKING TO THOSE WHO ARE INTO
IN OPPOSITION IN OPPOSITION. OF
SB TWO SIX SEVEN MADAME
MODERATOR. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
AT THIS TIME. ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. HOW WE LOOKING AT
A MODERATOR. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING TO
LAST CALL MATTER MODERATOR LAST
CALL FOR OPPOSITION LAST CALL
OPPOSITION PLEASE. THANK YOU IF
YOU WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU SO MUCH EIGHT
NICE WORKING WITH YOU TODAY
MATTER MODERATOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH WE'RE GOING TO BRING IT
BACK TO COMMITTEE QUESTIONS
COMMENTS- OR AND WE'RE ALSO
LOOKING FOR MOTION. PLEASE
MISTER ROGER I WOULD LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL THAT. THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR BY VICE CHAIR NIELSEN YOU
KNOW WHAT MOTION ON THE FLOOR
BY VICE YOU'RE NIELSEN ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE. HERRN
IN C. NINE MISTER MAJORITY
LEADER IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
YEAH I JUST WANT TO SAY ONE
THING YOU KNOW. IN THIS BILL IS
INDICATIVE OF A LARGER
DISCUSSION. WE HAVE AS POLICY
MAKERS HAVE BEEN DEALING WITH
THE VERY DIFFICULT CHALLENGE OF
CONVERTING OUR ENERGY SOURCES-
TO VARIOUS TYPES OF CLEAN
ENERGY. AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE
LOSS IN TWENTY OR TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO THESE WERE VERY
DIFFICULT TO DO. I WOULD SAY IN
THE LAST TWENTY YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE. WHETHER IT'S
RESOURCE ADEQUACY OR POLAR OR
ALL THE VARIOUS KINDS OF ISSUES
THAT WE FACE THESE KINDS OF.
BILLS WERE TRYING TO DEAL WITH
EXCLUSIONS OF SOLAR FROM
ASSESSED VALUATIONS AND HAVING
TO ADJUST BASED UPON THE
FEDERAL TAX CREDITS. ARE THE
KIND OF DISCUSSIONS THAT WE'RE
HAVING TO ENGAGE IN THE
LEGISLATURE YEAR AFTER YEAR AS
WE BEGIN THIS- AS WE I SHOULD
SAY CONTINUE THIS SIGNIFICANT
SHIFT. FROM THE OLD MODEL TO
THE NEW MODEL'S BATTERY STORAGE
FLEXIBILITY ALL OF THESE KINDS
OF ISSUES AND I. I JUST SAY
THIS IS ONE SMALL STEP IN A
VERY GIANT- ISSUE OF CONVERSION
AND- I THINK YOUR SUPPORT IN
THIS REGRD ASTRONOMICAL THANK
YOU SO MUCH AND MISTER MAJORITY
LEADER WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE
FLOOR THAT MOTION BY VICE CHAIR
NIELSEN IS A DO PASSED YOU
APPROPRIATIONS. SERVER NOW CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATOR MCGUIRE HI MCGUIRE HI
SENATOR NIELSEN HI NIELSEN HI
SENATOR DORADO HI TORONTO HI
SENATOR HERTZBERG HIGH.
HERTZBERG FIVE SENATOR WIENER.
WIENER I. THANK THE GERMAN
THAT'S A FIVE ZERO VOTE FIVE
ZERO VOTE THAT BILL IS THAT
WERE CLOSED THE ROLE ALL RIGHT
WE HAVE OUR CONSENT CALENDAR TO
BE A TO TAKE UP. THE MOST FOLKS
CAN HEAD ON OUT AND WE HOPE ALL
HAVE A SAFE AND ENJOYABLE
WEEKEND. LET'S TAKE UP OUR
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE EIGHT
ITEMS EIGHT ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE A
MOTION BY THE MAJORITY LEADER
IT TO MOVE IT THE CONSENT
CALENDAR- MISTER NOW PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. SENATOR MCGUIRE
HI WHY HI. NIELSEN NIELSEN FIVE
SENATE DURO. DRAWS HI SENATOR
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG HI SENATOR
WIENER. WIENER HI BUT AS FAR AS
YOUR VOTE FIVE ZERO VOTE THE
CONTENT COUNTER HAS BEEN
ADOPTED AND IT IS OUT WE ARE
GOING TO SAY THANK YOU TO
SENATOR ALSO VICE CHAIR NIELSEN
AND SENATOR WIENER FOR THEIR
WORK TODAY WE DO HAVE TWO BILLS
THAT REMAIN ON CALL AND THAT'S
GOING TO BE FOR THE MAJORITY
THERE THAT'S ITEM NUMBER ONE SB
SIX AND ITEM NUMBER TWO SB
SIXTY. ALL OTHER MEMBERS HAVE
VOTED ON ALL BILLS THANK YOU
VERY VERY MUCH ALL IN C.
TRAVELS- HOME MY GOODNESS THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER ALL RIGHT SO
NOW WE'RE GOING TO BE TURNING
IT OVER TO MR NOW IT'S
CURRENTLY EIGHTY AND ITEM
NUMBER ONE SB SIX THIS HAS A DO
PASSED A HOUSING MOTION
CURRENTLY ENJOYS A FOUR ZERO
VOTE MR NOW CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATOR HERTZBERG
YEAH HI AND ALSO I JUST WANTED
TO MENTION. SHOW HERTZBERG HIGH.
THAT IS FIVE FIVE ZERO WE'RE
CLOSING THE ROLE THE BILL OUT.
LAYS IN GERMAN WE HAVE ONE
FINAL BILL THAT'S ON CALL
THAT'S ITEM NUMBER TWO. SB
SIXTY BY CENTER GLAZER THE
MOTION WAS DUE TO PASS TO THE
FLOOR. CURRENTLY A FOUR ZERO
VOTE MISTER NOW. SENATOR
HERTZBERG. HERTZBERG HIGH FIVE
ZERO ENGINE ON FIVE ZERO VOTE
THE BILL IS OUT WE'RE CLOSER
ROLE ALL RIGHT. WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO THE GUY OF INFY
TEAM FROM OREGON SO SORRY
MISTER BOETTCHER PLEASE. JUST
AN OBSERVATION IF I MAY. AS WE
ARE PROGRESS SHE WE HAVE MANY
MANY BILLS COME BEFORE US. AND
CERTAINLY WE HAVE BEEN HELPING
THE SOLAR INDUSTRY EXPANDS AS
WE WILL SHOULD. BUT I WOULD
SUBMIT THAT OTHER FORMS OF
GENERATION OF ENERGY ARE ALSO
IMPORTANT WE MUST HAVE AN
ENERGY BASKET NOT JUST. ONE
BASKET BUT MANY. AND
PARTICULARLY HAND THIS IS A
PASSION OF SENATOR DOLLY AND
MYSELF. TO ELIMINATE SOME OF
OUR FIRE. PROBLEMS IN
CALIFORNIA AND MOST ASSUREDLY
TO HELP GENERATE ENERGY.
COGENERATION NEEDS TO BE
RESPECTED AND HELPED A LITTLE
BIT TOO SO I WOULD JUST SIMPLY
CALL OUT BUT LET'S LET'S PLAY A
LITTLE BIT OF ATTENTION TO
WHERE WE UTILIZE THE
AGRICULTURAL WASTE PRODUCTS AND
THE CLEANING OF OUR FORCE
GENERAL WILD LANDS TO GENERATE
ENERGY TO FAKE IT. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR VICE CHAIRMAN
ALRIGHT LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK
TO ALL THOSE HO ARE BEHIND THE
SCENES MAKING SURE LOOKS GOOD
INTO THE DEVON FIGHT TEAM AS
ALWAYS THANK YOU THIS MEETING
IS ADJOURNED OUR NEXT HEARING
WILL BE ON MARCH TWENTY FIFTH
THANK YOU. VERY YEAH I.